a huge announcement today came from the
pentagon american troops are going back
to afghanistan because the taliban has
made an obvious fierce comeback
look at the red all over that screen
when you look at the map of afghanistan
and no one expects this happened within
10 days
they've basically retaken almost the
entire country they're now in control of
two-thirds there are concerns that the
taliban could soon take over the capital
of kabul the bite administration is
responding by sending 3 000 u.s troops
to try to get the remaining personnel at
the u.s embassy out of kabul safely and
it comes months after president biden
announced this withdrawal from the u.s
forces of the region
he also just said i believe yesterday if
not the day before that he had no
regrets about the decision to pull out
of afghanistan i understand there was a
meeting last night at the white house
with the defense secretary and they and
the department of state as well and they
discussed all of this and decided they
were going to send 3 000 troops back in
and we're learning this afternoon this
evening that the kandahar uh the second
largest city which we knew was in danger
of falling has now also fallen so that
leaves only kabul uh left and that's
where the u.s embassy is brian uh your
thoughts on what we saw developed well
you covered great a couple hours ago on
your show uh three battalions marine and
one battalion marines are going in not
to help out and not to save kabul but to
get our people out this is one of the
ultimate embarrassments in my lifetime i
could imagine if i was cognizant of what
was going on in the world and when uh
saigon fell when we left south vietnam
and everyone said it was going to be
fine and obviously it wasn't so we now
have we could have left 2 500 troops and
avoided this whole total thing uh and
where is the president united states in
delaware the secretary of defense
general mattis did not approve of
president trump pulling out and leaving
the kurds naked in syria he quit and for
general austin to be in the ground as
long as he did and serve as long as he
did and get the applauded he got before
he got that job and for him to do this
and just follow orders not speak up and
not somehow get his way i think is
inexcusable admiral kirby knows better
but i watched him painfully try to say
is it's no big deal as we try to quickly
get our people out of kabul and guess
what happens
as we speak women are being burned alive
if their hair is exposed they're being
married off to taliban war fighters and
they're given up and running for the
hills not because they have no courage
because they have no leadership their
leaders left
their leaders weren't trained the u.s
left them at the doorstep and we left
without any knowledge without any plan
and we left irresponsibly and the world
is laughing at us and china is giggling
they can't believe how humiliated we are
we look as bad as the russians when they
ran for the hills in the 1980s and that
was the fall of the soviet empire which
is why we shouldn't have gone there in
the first place right you mean you're
looking at look look we would have to go
there
we went there 20 years ago on good faith
because of bin laden that was 20 years
ago times have changed regarding like
you brought up a point about madison the
kurds that's just a great example of how
we are lied to about things we were told
that if we left right all the kurds
would die have we heard anything about
that i think we're war weary at this
point and it's it's like you're in jail
and you're trying to stay awake and the
moment you fall asleep someone's going
to take your shoes so we're going to
stay awake forever in afghanistan are we
going to get to our advantage to be
there no china russia pakistan and
terrorists there
but right have a president right the
presence can be technology
we don't know what's going on on the
ground right now then that's why it's
left how are we have we been there for
20 years and we still don't know what's
on the ground we left but here you said
we've been there
it is but but here's the problem what
was the mission in the first place right
what was the mission in the first place
it absolutely but when you look at what
happened after that the building of
schools the protection of that area and
it is the national security interest of
the united states of america to have a
presence in that area to be able to have
uh to have eyes on the ground to be able
to get there quickly so now china and
russia are filling that void uh china is
watching what is happening so do we want
to fill the void they're not going to do
it let's try to be the third side 100
years people have been going into
you call this afghanistan
withdrawal because i spoke with
secretary pompeo today he said he cannot
believe what he is seeing on the ground
right now and that there's a responsible
way to get ourselves
training look your analogy to vietnam is
in some ways the perfect analogy is your
argument that now we should have
remained a presence in vietnam while
their civil war was going on if you just
there's
more well-read than you who know more
about history what if we had left south
korea what if we have left japan what
would that have done to uh our our uh
our influence in that region the
influence we've had in the region by
having a presence in 2014 we stopped
being on the offensive and we became in
the supporting role we haven't lost a
man or a woman in a year and a half
with 20 years of training of the afghan
military that they are not able to put
up a defense
means
we would just be the policeman in
afghanistan forever when when would we
leave we are the defense for japan we
are the defense essentially for south
korea what are you willing to do that in
afghanistan our presence there was
providing the stability in that region
and we kept an eye on al qaeda and this
new group called isis like when uh when
president obama thought it was a great
idea to leave iraq
here's what joe biden said not long ago
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people lifted off the roof
of an embassy
of the united states from afghanistan it
is not comparable
at all oops
kabul will follow 30 days this
administration and this administration's
foreign policy is that of miscalculation
and underestimation
and if they can't handle afghanistan oh
wait it's the the taliban's taking over
much faster than we thought leaving
behind women to suffer cruelly
what are what are we doing with china
like where does that leave us
oh that's right they're a competitor
they're not an enemy to talk to the
families of the what four and a half
million people that have died around the
globe because of the china virus this is
this is a stain on america for years to
come and it raises a multitude of
questions about the direction of our
relationships with any allies because we
just turned our backs on the people who
helped us and about the families and the
young men and women who lost their lives
in afghanistan uh who believed that they
were fighting for something that was
that was noble
and i don't know if one of them is yours
your child your son your daughter uh
what are you thinking right now as you
watch the entire thing go back to square
one that they died for nothing and it's
still salvageable i mean
it
if you want to look at this as a loss
it's a lost cause it's not you ah this
is a terrible saying no people fought
their valiant valiantly there we got bin
laden you is when do you say enough when
do you say do you want another 10 years
another 20 years you would be there
forever that that's a right people
logically are think that's a logical
question and you can't demean people
because they they think that maybe they
want their kids
character you're mischaracterizing the
situation on the ground and you are
right if you bring that up and you have
brought it up in the past about
president trump's this is president
trump's plan okay i got it didn't agree
with it then and i've said it maybe not
on this show number two is you're not
asked this is not a hot war greg your
point is well taken if this is maybe
2010 and you know we're losing a dozen
guys here and a dozen guys there what's
going on what's the plan i get it but
this is not a hot war this was a holding
and we had influence in that region and
you had a generation of afghans and
these horrible people called women who
had actually a chance to live their
lives because of our presence and they
don't understand what we did well with
the 20th anniversary of 9 11 coming up
next month how long do we have to wait
before a terrorist group al qaeda or a
new one regroups in that area of the
country and attacks the united states
because that's that's the i mean that
was the the original mission is to make
sure that it's not a safe haven for
terrorists who attack us here and
whether or not we're going to see that
back-peddled um and also the 911 the 911
pull-out date was an artificial date uh
the fact that president biden wanted to
leave on september 11th to have that
complete on that date on the 20th
anniversary i think is you know there's
a lot of uh legitimate questions raised
about the decision to do that all right
we're gonna leave it there on that